all right we are now live for another
ama that's ask me anything session let's
see if i get the lights up a little bit
i know that sometimes
people uh
uh think these are a little bit dark
not just because of the content
but because of the
there you go the lighting so we've got a
couple questions already lined up in
advance um some of which are better than
others
damn it albert says do you agree with
some of the more extreme interpretations
of foucault that suggests that a real me
uninfluenced by my society's discourses
and epi epistemes or epi stems however
we want to pronounce that doesn't
actually exist
um yeah i mean
and so would most ancient philosophers
and medieval philosophers
depending on what you mean by real me i
mean
you don't have to go to foucault to
think that we are influenced
incredibly
by society that's a viewpoint of plato
and aristotle and
epicurus think about the role that vain
or
illusory opinions play this is not
something radically new the notion that
there is some sort of core that's you
that's like totally unchanging and and
would be you know unaffected by any sort
of cultural things is a little bit um
a little bit of a an odd notion
um i don't know
too many people who buy into that or if
they do they're like well you got like
the transcendental ego and it does its
thing and then you've got your empirical
self um now maybe you're asking about
something else like
you know is there like nothing that we
can take for granted or no local
continuities or anything like that
um
but i don't i don't see that as like a
particularly
uh extreme interpretation or foucaultian
thing um as you're as i was reading and
i was thinking about the the who song
that was covered by wasp i think it's a
better actual um
cove better version the real me you know
uh can you see the real me um can you
can you
um you know it depends on what we're
talking about the real me in that song
is
kind of a weird guy right
so very culturally conditioned i would
say
doesn't mean that everything is like
totally culturally determined
um all right so
ff has a bunch of questions i'm going to
answer one of them because i like to
answer you know one at a time rather
than piling up every all those by
one single person
and i'm not going to give everything
that he's looking for to expand my
nietzsche repertoire seven works to
kierkegaard dostoevsky sart and tolstoy
could you objectively recommend the
works i need to read by these authors
like seven works max for each one
i'm not going to give you seven works
this is not a like um
tally everything up thing for each
author i mean if you want to read
nietzsche i'll and i'll just stick with
nietzsche right i mean if you want to
get an idea about who's important in
existentialism check out my
existentialism playlist you know or my
uh many writings out there about it or
the videos that i've got about who are
the existentialists and that'll that'll
probably get you squared away but let's
think about nietzsche so
at a minimum i would say if you want to
understand nietzsche well
you want to read the birth of tragedy
that's an early work nietzsche himself
will criticize it but it's still very
important and it articulates some some
key things
you want to read the spoke zarathustra
in part because that was part of what
built his reputation
and he references zarathustra you want
to read the genealogy of morals because
that is the
more systematic presentation of his
later ideas
and i would say um you know you could
pick and choose whatever else you want
to read i think beyond good and evil is
a good
place to go right
so yeah that'll work um
ozzie mandias is it possible to make
truth or value claims within an
existentialist epistemological framework
without the claim being reduced to pure
personal preference
yes because there's many forms of
existentialism and there is no such
thing as an existentialist
epistemological
framework i don't know where you're
getting that from but
um the existentialists were
not
really working in those terms
maybe got that from some somebody else's
uh summary of existentialism but there
isn't like a an existentialist here's
our checklist about what it means to
belong to the movement it's a pretty
wide diverse movement and it's not like
existentialists think that everything is
totally reduced to personal preference
um
not even not even cert you know
so
things do hold together they just don't
have some absolute you know overarching
pre-figured meaning that you can rely
upon but you want to figure out whether
when you're talking about existentialism
you want to figure out who do you
actually have in mind are you talking
about sartre are you talking about kamu
are you talking about de bouvoir just
three figures that are already close
together are you talking about gabriel
marcel and other french existentialist
who is in many respects quite different
than them first guy to use the word
existentialist in french by the way
are you talking about
nietzsche are you talking about some
literary figures like kafka or rilka are
you talking about lav shestoff are you
talking about una muno you know you
gotta
you've gotta clarify there is no
existentialist per se that's part of you
know the meaning of the movement isn't
it um
jd sword good to see you here uh what
kind of attitude should we hold towards
the future with covet and climate change
it seems increasingly hard to be
positive
is a defeatist attitude reasonable i
mean that's that's really up to you
um you don't have to satisfy the demands
of universal human reason in order to
have the standpoint that that you have i
mean it's it's commendable that you want
there to be some reasonability to your
affective life but it's not like that is
some sort of imperative that we all
should be either positive or negative or
somewhere in between and that you know
only one of those is
is rational it depends very much on
where you sit and what you value so
you know if you
think that
it really sucks that the environment is
being degraded at a rapid rate and that
our political gridlock and the fact that
our
you know capacities to
change things are very limited by the
uh sorry crop of politicians that we've
got who are like totally worthless on
the republican end and halfway worthless
on the democrat end and that
corporations um and you know other just
rich people have have a ton of influence
over them that sucks but then the
question is well does that mean that i
have to think everything is crap um
no i mean that that is in many respects
up to you
um things can have value things can be
good even if they are going to be finite
and have an end even if like you know
nuclear war happened tomorrow
if i do something good for my wife or
some homeless guy on the street or you
know in this this discussion here that
good was real and it existed and you can
choose to focus on that or you can
choose to focus on the
it's all going to crap kind of thing
which hopefully is not the case man
maybe something will happen uh and we'll
we'll get out of this
it's understandable i will say this
that it does feel harder to be positive
kovid
[Music]
you know the covet
19
and our screwed-up response to it um
largely driven by uh
crazy conspiracy stuff
and uh people profiting off of that and
then the complete
um you know
essentially intellectual breakdown of of
the the right and the republican party
here in the united states into
opportunistic loons um
which really hampered our covid response
um that can be dismaying
you know the fact that we can we can get
sick and die because um we couldn't
we the the society couldn't get its act
together and ensure some basic health
and hygiene stuff that can be
demoralizing but it doesn't it doesn't
have to
it doesn't have to be as demoralizing as
i think a lot of people make it who are
looking for
big term solutions kovid really revealed
to us just how screwed up
many of us knew things to be already
because it laid additional stresses on
our systems so i think that's probably
all that i have to say about that
um made of clay has some very general
questions that are kind of tough to
answer
is there more philosophy in english
departments than in philosophy
departments and what are some things you
don't like about the philosophy
departments today i mean so one of the
things that i do have to say is there is
an incredible vast diversity
in american higher education so
it's not like there is an archetype of
philosophy department that you can point
at because it's different from place to
place and indeed some of the places
where i teach or have taught don't even
have philosophy departments but have
philosophy classes
for example when i was at fayetteville
state university we had a philosophy
minor and we taught a lot of critical
thinking classes but we did not have a
philosophy program we were under the
department of government and history
milwaukee area technical college
obviously does not have a
philosophy program they only have three
philosophy classes and one they added
recently
milwaukee institute of art and design
does not have a philosophy program i am
i am the philosophy guy there they
brought me in to kind of add some of
that to the curriculum and carthage
college just recently got rid of their
philosophy department which was very
small
um just just two guys
and then you know some adjuncts like
myself and um
they they did that essentially to like
trim
personnel
they still have philosophy classes i'm
teaching medieval philosophy they're
next semester and i'm teaching business
ethics this semester so just at like
those institutions we can say
there's a wide diversity
between how philosophy is done is it
done more in english departments i
wouldn't say so i would say some authors
get taught more in english departments
but they often get taught
not
in the mode of doing philosophy but
rather you know focusing on their
literary stuff so you probably do have
more mary wollstonecraft being taught in
english departments than philosophy
departments
but
they're probably not just focusing on
vindication of the rights of women or
the vindication of the rights of man but
also on her letters from scandinavia
um her various novels and you know
letters and things like that so
you know
are there things i don't like about the
way philosophy is done
here in the united states kind of
generally
yeah and i've talked about some of that
i think that
intro classes ethics classes these
things that we call service classes
are you know very important and often
get treated as if they are the slums and
we're wasting our time with these
non-major students when really those
those should be the most important
classes
and everybody should have to teach them
and everybody should be evaluated on how
they teach them so if you're you know
some big shot
only teaches graduate classes professor
maybe you should get reigned in because
you can't effectively teach undergrads
well somebody by the way who did do
very good teaching for undergraduates
and chose to do so aleister mcintyre at
notre dame when he could have like said
i'm only doing graduate students from
now on
he said i'm teaching undergrads
so
yeah um
let's see here abu says greetings
professor extremely grateful for your
contribution to my intellectual growth
i'm glad glad to read that yeah and and
um i think it's important
to to think about this as
you know
the most that we can do
like with youtube videos or stuff like
that
is offer you resources which then it's
up to you to do something with right to
read the books to think about it to go
through the growth we can offer you
some
some useful you know structure and
resources and and attaboy every once in
a while
but um it's really you know it's really
what you do with it that that counts
um
let's see here
[Music]
shafia i'm a kid i have this question no
one's answering for me um that's that
sounds like you know
uh what happens a lot in school is the
brain controlling us or are we
controlling it and the answer is yes
both i mean our brain is not different
from us
it's a significant locus of the us
that's us or the me that's me right
take my brain out i don't know that
there's i mean there's a lot of medical
waste left because i'm dead
but
um i don't know that there's an awful
lot left i mean you can say that we have
an extended mind in many respects you
know in a certain way so i've got my my
book sitting here right
this is sort of an extension of me at
one time and other other people's brains
as well because i translated their works
um but you know it's still mostly
in the wet wear up in our skulls
and what's cool about the brain
is that it is a reflexive organ right so
the brain can think about the brain the
brain can picture the brain the brain is
already in the process of modifying the
brain and so who controls what you know
there's a bit of self-control there
isn't there
um
all right uh john uh not philosophy
related but any advice for someone who's
gonna be teaching for the first time at
a high school um
no advice
but some uh
you know
what would you call it
i'll just say
more power to you um you know somebody's
got to do that with with those kids it's
not something that i could do myself
um so for those who can do it thank god
that they are because otherwise we would
have just a whole generation of little
not even barbarians
roaming around right we every every
generation we have to teach it all again
to these students which includes not
just teaching the information but even
teaching like how to acquire the
information
and there's so much that we have to
impart to kids and you can see the
effects of not doing that
um in so many people so
that's great that you're going to be
teaching high school but i don't i don't
actually have an awful lot
to um
to do i'm going to remind people because
i see somebody like you know asking
questions over and over and over again
ask once um you're not going to get much
more by
by
posting it more than once you're
basically wasting everybody else's time
and space by doing that
so
all right uh
what do we got next
um
john holloway in some of your lectures
on epictetus's discourse as you start in
book two and jump around do you think
there's certain books chapter that
should be read first or should it be
read linearly it should be read
over and over and over again that's the
answer to your question it doesn't
matter whether you read it linearly or
whether you read it jumping around but
you should be reading it like any
philosophical text many many times
um and as you do that you will come to
realize that titus's
discourses which he did not write but
were written by his his uh people arias
or aryan
um
were
not arranged in a sort of systematic
order
um
so it doesn't matter if you start with
chad one you know from book one or
whether you start in book four
um and i don't jump around i'm i've been
reading epictetus long enough like you
know by the time i shot those videos 25
years to be able to know what sections
are relevant to other sections just like
if you're doing thomas aquinas
and you go to the summa teologia thomas
never tells you everything that there is
to know in any particular
question and article that's titled you
know about anger or something like that
there's going to be all sorts of other
things scattered throughout his work
that are relevant and the better that
you get to understand an author
the more you do what appears to you
skipping around which is really
correlating all the different connected
discussions
um so i mean the answer to how you
should read it is
read it often and read it over and over
again and these sort of questions about
do you have to read it you know
sequentially moot point you know if you
do that
um
cognitive psychology phd what's your
thoughts on the closest theory to the
objective truth overall i don't know
what objective truth is supposed to mean
there's so many things that objective
means it's called kind of an ambiguous
term so
there's no answer for that one
um
okay so a bunch of uh questions here by
agor
about fourth political theory alexander
dugan you got to actually frame your
your question as a question please
explain it
i don't i'm not a dugan person so no
idea why you're you know looking for
answers about that why not read dugan
yourself right or find somebody who's
particularly interested in him
james says how much of nietzsche's
hatred of christianity was of
christianity proper and how much was his
hatred of plato and seeing christianity
as platonism for the masses i would say
neither um is it's not like he as as a
kid the you know son of a
you know lutheran uh who by the way as a
kid to show the other kids that the
saints could probably you know have the
sort of wills that they did held a hot
piece of metal in his hand
nietzsche's relationship with
christianity is complex
it's not
just this just that
um the whole you know christianity is
platonism for the masses
is on the one hand kind of a cool
throwaway quote um that doesn't really
tell you that much unless you understand
what platonism is supposed to mean
um and how christianity is supposed to
correlate with it and on the other hand
if you dig into it and you do that then
you can oh now now i see what nietzsche
is really after
here
[Music]
i think you can say he did have a hatred
for christianity but he also i mean
again read the birth tragedy
and you'll see that his attitude towards
christianity is quite complex
there's christianity as a doctrine
there's christianity as a church there's
christianity as centered around the
figure of christ
and he has different attitudes towards
each of these and different attitudes
from book to book so
yeah
all right um
andrew says do you have a recommended
reading list when starting off reading
philosophy if so where could i find it
i mean i do
for beginners but it's you know in
any sort of reading list
when it comes to that you should always
take with a grain of salt right
i have a uh
10 books that i recommend to beginner
you could probably just put that in
google you know 10 books sadler and a
medium article will pop up and that came
out of a conversation that i had with my
friend and colleague
leia on her common sense ethics blog
and then i turned it into a medium piece
and interestingly enough it is by far
the most red medium piece that i have at
this point in time i think there's like
you know tens of thousands of people
have read it um
so if you just google um sadler 10 books
beginners
it'll it'll come up right off the bat
uh mark says how's it going hope you're
keeping well yeah pretty good here um
[Music]
we you know
we've had a couple interesting things
happen locally if anybody has been
following it our
star quarterback aaron rodgers
for the green bay packers has tested
positive for covid and it turned out
that he lied about whether he was
actually vaccinated against it and then
when offered the opportunity to explain
himself
went off into conspiracy rant land using
all of like the code words you know woke
cancel culture and so he's he's just he
came out as a nutter
very very disappointing and a terrible
lack of
leadership and responsibility on his
part he may have sunk his boat you know
so that's kind of a big story around
here there's also been an interesting
development on twitter
where
i don't know who that was organizing
this but they did a brackets thing for
american cities and people would vote
about you know which city is better than
which city and milwaukee's in there
and milwaukee recently
made it to the semi-finals and then beat
chicago
which which makes sense because even
though chicago has more people as a city
there's a lot of things that suck about
chicago that don't suck about milwaukee
um and i can speak as somebody who knows
both of them very very well you know
i've got a lot of family in the chicago
area i've lived in the chicagoland area
and i now live here in milwaukee and
apparently milwaukee also just beat new
york
so so that's kind of a cool thing too
other other stuff you know we we went
last night my wife and i to see this uh
big cats uh thing at the bradley center
which was originally scheduled for my my
birthday last year
but due to covid um it got it got put
off and and so we got we finally went to
the event and that was kind of cool as
this guy national geographic
photographer showing pictures and clips
and talking about you know
photographing all these big cats and
then some of the big problems that are
that are faced by them as well so that's
that's how's it going and the other
thing is my students are like
thanksgiving break cannot come soon
enough for those poor kids or for me
so that's what's going on
um
let's see here
god says have you read anything of
kazajakis don't even know who that
refers to so no
uh gaussian eagle greetings from poland
first time in here well welcome to it
uh ff thanks for all how are your humor
in terms of laugh smile and comedy the
stuff that makes you laugh oh you know i
like to i there's a lot of good stuff
out there
either in like the various streaming
platforms like hulu or
netflix or amazon
prime or hbo max and i've always got
like some funny show i've been watching
swedish dicks lately which is very very
funny uh that's uh that's on amazon
prime and i've also been watching lower
decks i don't know if any of you have
been watching that but that's that's
pretty good too i i enjoy that um
you know and there's also we like what i
like watching i can't speak for my my
wife i think she'll humor me on this um
you know british comedy shows especially
scots ones for some reason a lot of
funny stuff and oftentimes you can find
things on youtube right so
i you know i like to watch um
shows
uh and and laugh a bit about that
there's enough other stuff we can laugh
about i mean one of going back to um um
gerald sword's thing about like you know
the really crappy environment that we do
live in
what should our response be to it
sometimes it's okay to laugh you know
and it can be a bitter laugh or it can
be a sardonic laugh or it can be a
sarcastic laugh but there's something
about
laughing that
is better than crying as seneca points
out you know
all
right m.a are you familiar with written
asia rard or memetic theory i am indeed
jesse what do you think of bad you just
started reading being an event and it
seems cool
um i'm just not into bad you he's
somebody who i know a little bit about
but not much about
i will say that my wife has studied with
him and actually acted in his play and
and received the great accolade that she
was the most ahmed of ahmed's um
so you know he seems like a cool guy but
you know who's got the time to read
everybody you know
um so
not really i don't really have much to
say about him
uh union when can we hope for some
schopenhauer well definitely when the
semester's over because this semester if
you haven't noticed i have been
producing a lot of videos on ursula k le
guin's earth sea
six book series and so that has occupied
a great amount of my time
trying to do that and you know events
like this and the half hour hegel series
and
stuff like that has more or less tapped
me out so
i would say in the new year
unless something radically changes
uh
vince and andrew your thoughts on
bergson marilla pontian jung
that's kind of a weird mix to put
together there
um berkshome underrated philosopher i
very much enjoy reading him
um i think that he's he's uh well worth
checking out and going back to
uh merlot ponte also kind you know was a
big deal in his time
um
not that red
these days well worth reading
um phenomenology perception is the big
work of course but he's got a lot of
other good stuff as well
and jung
i'm not a fan of jung
i you know i've read quite a bit i don't
buy the archetype stuff and i think that
a lot of the people who talk about jung
very often the fact that they you know
like get so worked up about archetypes
or the shadow or stuff like that
it's a sign to me that it's not it's not
really worth my time to engage in
conversation they can do that on their
own
i do like what jung has to say about
other people quite often and that's what
i consider to be some of the best parts
of his works
he's often kind of insightful
and witty so but i'm not a jungian in
any respect so
all right awful philosophy evening do
you have any advice how to get into
phenomenology husserl's just so
inaccessibly dry yeah um it's kind of
that's kind of an interesting thing to
to
start with so
yeah who is cereal is boring
the host rule is very dry it's like
reading jeremy bentham it it's worth
doing right but hussarl was a boring
phenomenologist and husserl scholars
they're kind of a weird little clique of
their own and you can there's like a
stick that goes with them i've known
quite a few over the years and as a
matter of fact i did my master's thesis
under one of them
i did my master's thesis on husserl and
his passive synthesis lectures um
that said if you are going to read just
role
husserl himself has an encyclopedia
botanical article on phenomenology and
when i when i used to teach
husserole you know like in a continental
philosophy class i would use that and
his cartesian meditations
um which are
pretty accessible there's a lot of
terminology stuff but you know you can
see what he's doing
there's a lot of other really great
phenomenologists that are contemporaries
of husserl
i mean britano is is well worth checking
out
um mock shaler
brilliant phenomenologist very
interesting to read
a lot of fun
and just as important as husserl
heidegger of course you know john paul
sartre is a phenomenologist
gabriel marcel is a phenomenologist eat
it stein you know there's lots and lots
of other people that you can read from
that early period by the way aleister
mcintyre has a biography of edith stein
who
in which he sort of like lays out what
the intellectual
field was like at the time so i would i
would actually check that out
um
so you know that's early phenomenology
and i think once you
get your feet wet in that you can find
all sorts of other cool people who are
doing interesting
stuff some of them you probably have
never heard of like you know if you're
interested in phenomenology and
philosophy of religion john ehring is
you know h-e-r-h-e-r-i-n-g
would be like one of the people that you
you go to but nobody reads them anymore
right i'm not even sure if his stuff has
been translated but
um
yeah there's a lot of cool people in
phenomenology and then there's like
people still doing it in the present and
you can go online just you know google
like phenomenology society you're gonna
find websites of people dedicated to
doing it in the present and so
um connecting up with them can be kind
of fun right
dator says what are your thoughts of ted
kaczynski
and his critique of society and
technology so i have to say i don't know
it that well i've never read his
manifesto
it's something i've actually wanted to
do for a while but just you know haven't
found the time to because
you know i i read things
that other people have written and
they're like yeah there's there's you
know
this isn't just ravings there's
something here and i'm like well i
should probably check it out but i i
don't have enough
uh
to say about it so
uh
let's see here just skipped a little bit
vincent is every psychoanalysis theory
could be considered as philosophy
probably not
i mean you could say that every and
let's expand it beyond psychoanalysis
psychological and psychotherapeutic
could every theory be considered as
philosophy
it can be considered to have
philosophical assumptions or
underpinnings like anything else i mean
if you're doing sociology
or any of these other fields that that
spun out of philosophy you are doing
some philosophy but probably without
realizing it you know
same thing with economics same thing
with pick whatever you want um
but there are some that are probably
much more philosophically informed than
than others you could say i mean classic
psychoanalysis those people all knew
quite a bit of philosophy because they
had gone through a
university system that had you reading
that early on and and it was part of
general culture um
would american psychoanalysts of the you
know 1990s through the 2020s know much
philosophy it really depends on the
psychoanalyst probably a lot of them
don't know much at all unless they're
you know into somebody who's
who's uh quite interested in philosophy
so
all right um
let's see here
[Music]
i'm gazia eagle are we a piece of meat
yeah you're not just a piece of meat
you're a whole bunch of pieces of meat
you got your organs you got you know
all the different cuts that you could
make all the different muscle groups so
uh yeah you're you're uh uh there's a
lot of meat to a person all right
uh thomas is nice dude sweater yeah my
wife got this for me years and years ago
because people when i first started uh
teaching and i was you know on youtube
i'd been teaching for 10 years at that
time i had my hair down a lot and and i
guess the way that i look and the way
that i talk reminded quite a few people
of the dude so she thought it would be
kind of funny to get me the sweater
which is very nice i you know it's cold
here and i i wear it a lot in the winter
i might do some videos someday when i
have the time as the dude
we'll see about that
all right uh
punit says i feel so sleepy whenever i
start
you read a book
uh to read a book i'm assuming right
coffee helps with that um
maybe sitting up i don't know you know
fresh air that sort of thing
uh
kasyan i really appreciate your videos i
was wondering whether you've done a
video detailing your current
philosophical views on a related note
have you done the phil papers survey
i've looked at the fill paper survey
those of you who don't know what we're
referencing here so there's there's phil
papers is a website and they do a survey
every once in a while a really crappy
survey in my view because of the way
it's constructed it's very off on you
know one way or the other and it asks
about a lot of the isms that people are
into in contemporary analytic philosophy
and it doesn't ask about much of
anything else
and i i view it as a waste of time it's
not it's not representative it's poorly
constructed but
you know there you have it you know um
my own views my own philosophical views
i i mean i did a piece a thing in my
philosophical developments about
eclecticism i am a cicerone eclectic you
know that means that
i draw on you know a number of other
people
and you know a little bit of this here a
lot of this here try to put them
together there's a constant effort to
try to overcome contradictions
uh and figure out what sources are best
you could call this pluralism if you're
more of a william james kind of person
there's a lot of names for it
but um i i am not a
um
particularly one single way committed
kind of kind of person
and you know a lot of the people who i
like from history aren't that way too so
um
he demons if you had to choose which
main philosophers
the average person should acquaint
themselves with who would it be and why
uh
i mean that's
i i mentioned that piece that i wrote
like 10 philosophical books that
beginners could start with easy enough
to google or you can find it on my my
medium site
and you know that was picking a top 10
is kind of tough
there's this tendency to like always say
oh yeah but also this person this person
and this person right
um
i mean you definitely
want to know ancient
philosophy so you should you should read
plato and
um do you have to read everything plato
wrote no i don't think so uh you know
and some aristotle and you know the
stoics what we have of them at the
epicureans
the little that we have of them
um it's good to read you know uh some of
the skeptics stuff like sexist empiricus
you wouldn't have to read everything the
guy wrote obviously
cicero is great i think
i'm a big fan of of plutarch and
alexander of aphrodisias and a lot of
these early
christian
thinkers as well
um and some of the later neoplatonists
um that's that's just ancient philosophy
right
and you know you could go on and like
everybody probably should read descartes
and not just in a half-assed way like
you know just trying to get through the
book to get through it everybody
probably should read descartes
meditations at one point in their their
life and really read it and everybody
probably should read
the first two books of hobbes leviathan
not not the weird wacky crazy theology
that only hobbes buys into in part three
and part four
um
and there's other texts along the way as
well but it's tough to say what they
what they should be right because every
time we do that like the list just gets
monumental
um
so yeah
all right uh
let's see here
ha ha says if you had to choose between
reading only metaphysics epistemology or
ethics for the rest of your life which
would you choose
i mean you don't have to because some
books are all three right
and those those all blend into each
other i mean
you you know
ethics is inevitably going to lead into
both metaphysics and and epistemology
and epistemology already raises ethical
questions and stuff like that so i don't
i don't think that i i i would be able
to answer that well
um
let's see
shafia says sorry to ask again how can i
be a good thinker and writer suggest
some books that will help me please
reply
i mean
you want to be a good writer read other
good writers spend a lot of time reading
other good writers you want to be a good
thinker see what those writers have to
say
and you know question them along the way
and learn from them and
this is the same advice that so many
other people give i'll add one other
thing from ursula k le guin you want to
be a good writer right right right right
you have to keep writing and you have to
do a lot of crappy writing before you're
going to become good
are there books to help with this i mean
the books that you're going to be
reading you know so
read good literature
read read good essayists writing about
good literature ursula k leguin would be
one of them right
um but there's so many others as well
read read virginia woolf read uh
uh what um
[Music]
uh
people like lewis and chesterton have to
say not just in their their uh own
stuff but about other thinkers read
graham green's film reviews uh for some
really crazy stuff stuff that almost got
him beaten up by by people who had
produced the films
the way that you get good at there isn't
like a book out there how to become a
good thinker how to become a good writer
it's
engaging in in that field
uh michael james who is your favorite
philosopher from the high middle ages
other than aquinas for me things start
to get strange in scotus and ockham well
it depends on where we count the high
middle ages is starting if we push it
back far enough obviously and some
because he's the guy i've written the
most about and have a particular
attachment to
i'm i'm less into these scholastic
writers and more into the monastic
writers you know
um
so
uh
andrew has a good question here when
you're going through a difficult and
stressful time what philosophy do you
find yourself turning to how do you
apply that philosophy at the moment i
mean this is where eclecticism
becomes very helpful
if you're not just like a i'm a stoic
and that's how i do everything or i may
this or i'm of that you have a much
wider
repertoire to draw upon and there's no
one single answer to how do you apply it
you know it that's where prudence comes
in figuring out what to what to use in
in what situations
um
i draw very heavily on stoicism on the
aristotelian tradition
on
some you know um platonism less from
plato much more from the you know middle
and late platonists
um from existentialist authors from
dialectical authors
from
some phenomenologist mark schaeler is a
great example i remember when i was i
was going through a particularly bad
breakup
and as as you do when you have a
terrible breakup you feel like you know
the world is over and you'll never love
again and all that sort of stuff and i
remember i was on southern illinois
campus
and i was riding my bike back home to my
trailer on the south side of town
and i was feeling so so blue you know
and then i started thinking about what
mock shaler might have to say about the
situation that i was in
and as i was riding i realized that
while i was still feeling really down a
part of me was no longer down because it
was like thinking through this this
thing as almost like a
a problem not a problem to be solved but
a problem something thrown in front of
you as a problem means
to
to think about and scrutinize and see
through this this lens
and i realized that my spirits had
picked up uh by doing that i hadn't
become like happy or something but i
didn't feel this was crappy
now that's an application but is that
something that you can say well okay so
when i'm in a situation i need to think
about a mock shaler idea and what he
would say about it it doesn't work quite
that way it's it's instead you stock
your mind up this is why the stoics by
the way over and over again in their
works like epictetus and seneca will say
you know remind yourself of this or
consider this or when in a situation
tell yourself this right and they're
they're telling you to stock up your
mind with useful stuff that you won't
know how useful it is until you get into
a situation so
all right uh thomas what comedians do
you think are funny it seems like
comedians can get away with saying
things a lot of people can't because
they're just funny and poking around i
mean it depends on the comedian right
um
again it's for me it's like less
individual comedians and more
shows that that i
enjoy watching um
so
you know there are some really great
like comedy
teams like the guys for example who did
uh bonus town um
was scott's show a while back or chew in
the fat an older show
turns out there's connections sometimes
between them
um
[Music]
you know another another brit show that
we we particularly enjoyed
was and i i was not expecting to enjoy
it
actually there's two that have have one
one guy in common
another greg
cuckoo and
oh now i'm blanking on her name i can
see the the lead actress uh rosen
connody in it
um
[Music]
game face you know and then you know
we'll we'll watch like saturday night
live and
sometimes it's good sometimes it sucks
some of the people on it are very funny
some of them are
some of them are not um you know so i
don't have like a repertoire of
particular comedians i'm like super into
um
all right uh
colors of gaming i'm just now dabbling
in philosophy stoicism i'm curious how
someone can be both passionate for
change in your surroundings politics or
culture while still being stoic well
you've got to understand stoicism well
so you want to do a lot of work to
actually do that it's not something that
you can like get a few quotes from and
then start applying
that's fake stoicism
um the stoics have an entire theory of
emotions
best book on that margaret graves
stoicism and emotion but there's plenty
of resources out there and you can find
the emotions discussed in seneca and in
uh at different points in epictetus and
marcus aurelius and then you know aries
didymus and
and uh um diogenes layer tastes
summaries of stoic doctrine the stoics
didn't think that you couldn't have
emotions about things you they had to be
within the scope of of reason
human rationality
so
you know
you can you can
be committed
about a cause and be you know doing so
as a stoic i mean
stoics fought in the civil war cato
was dead against uh caesar right even
though pompey was kind of a scumbag too
um cicero and cato both both you know
lined up against them to the detriment
of cato's life and eventually uh in a
different way of cicero's life
so it's perfectly
possible to be committed to social
change and be a stoic
you just want to go further into the
literature to see how that how that's
the case
um
in shrek what do you think about the
mistranslation of the word auf heimong
to abolition in the communist manifesto
and how it created a huge
misunderstanding of marxism i don't know
that it created a huge
you know misunderstanding of marxism so
you know i that's that's not
it's not something i can really comment
on abolition is not really a good
translation of auf heibong if it's meant
in a hegelian way
because um hegelian auf heibong
does involve like transcending something
or going past something
and perhaps also leaving something of
what's being transcended behind but it
also means incorporating as well so just
abolishing something
isn't the same thing although hegel
himself will sometimes use alf haven or
auf heibong
in ways that are different from this as
well um
you know where it could mean something
just like canceled out or
um
superseded is often like miller likes
that sometimes so
yeah
bruce has some good advice about dugan
scholars here glad to see bruce here um
[Music]
and uh
oh here's a really interesting question
by roughly bumble
is there a 20th century figure you
believe most you exemplified most of the
classical virtues
so
and let's talk let's think in terms of
just to make it simple the classical
virtues let's use the cardinal virtues
let's not go into aristotle's kind of
extended list
um so wisdom justice temperance and
courage and i would say yeah i mean i i
mentioned aleister mcintyre in here that
i've interacted with the guy i'd say
he's got the virtues he's a virtue
ethicist who talks the talk and walks
the walk
um my interactions with christopher gill
and julia annis lead me to believe now
they're you know obviously all three of
these people are also 21st century
figures because they've managed to
survive into the 21st century
mcintyre is 93 if i if i remember right
uh gill and honest are fortunately you
know considerably younger
but are are definitely getting up there
but did a lot of work prior to the
21st century
um and i would say they they seem to be
people who have the virtues as well um i
mean who else should we think about
biographically
um that's a good question did gabriel
marcel
exemplify the the virtues
a lot of the time some of the time he
could be kind of a uh you know prickly
jerk
um you know you look at his his
criticisms like so
marcel was a christian existentialist
um bouvoir
sartre and camus who later fell out with
each other sart and bouvoir together
with against kamu they were um all
atheistic existentialists and they would
often say bad stuff about each other and
i i kind of think that
like camus uh response to marcel's
criticisms of his plays i think are
actually on point um but marcel was a
good guy in general
um
i mean who else i'm sure there were lots
and lots of people it's difficult to say
sometimes right because we
we don't know these people that well um
and we were dependent either on
biographers or on personal acquaintance
with them
so
michael says as a packers fan i'm very
disappointed with aaron rodgers i am too
you know i i i've often stood up for him
uh because there's a lot of haters out
there i think that in the past he did in
fact make a lot of
good points and uh decisions about stuff
in terms of the management of the team
it's interesting
that you notice that he would kind of
fence it when it came to
important uh issues
for example having to do with kaepernick
and the kneeling thing right
um and maybe
now we look back at rogers and we're
like
maybe he was actually you know somebody
who who uh harbored these ideas back
then about woke crowds and canceling and
stuff like that or maybe it's just
adventitious and he's and he's crazy for
covin you know
um i don't know but but the recent stuff
and his justification of it
it's tough to come back from that you
know
and i think it's going to affect the
team
um
so yeah
isaac do you have a particular stoic
text you enjoy teaching more than any
other that's a good that's a great
question um
yeah so i don't i don't teach all of
them right
uh when i'm teaching stoicism it's
usually drawing
mostly from
epictetus or seneca or even cicero i
don't usually teach marcus aurelius in
part because the the meditations are so
disjointed it's jumping around i mean
you want to talk about a work that that
is unsystematic
um you know the the the different books
other than book one the gratitude
journal
um
there's no like one single common theme
running through them whereas at least
with seneca you've got to work like you
know um on the happy life well you can
expect that it's going to be mostly
about the happy life right
or a letter of consolation or you know
with epictetus there's like chapter
headings um
i
i like epictetus more than the others i
have to say he's always been my favorite
so i guess maybe
i like teaching him the best he's also
kind of raw and salty like me he's not
afraid to like call people out and say
well that's a dumb question or you know
i i don't like say slave you know or
stuff like that but i kind of like that
i like being a straight you know
straight shooter with people
about stuff so
uh
zenith says how do you feel about
changing philosophies are you concerned
with consistency or is it okay to change
religion's philosophy i don't see why
consistency
it precludes changing philosophies if
you're consistent and you think
you come to have better information
and you realize that something that you
bought into in the past
turned out to be you know
lacking or inadequate in in certain
respects then consistency would actually
have you follow through
and say i'm going to leave this behind
or at least i have to attenuate my my
commitment to this
um
so i don't know that they're really um
i don't know that they're really uh
incompatible that way matter of fact
genuine consistency might require you
when you find out that something
you know okay so let's use this this uh
aaron rodgers thing right
uh so in the past i've i've said that
rogers was a good leader he made good
decisions here's the reasons why you
know now he's he's done some you know
really dumb stuff uh in just you know in
the last week he did more to undermine
himself than he's done to build himself
up over the last 17 years
and could we you know if i'm being
consistent does that mean that i say oh
no no it's this is not that bad you know
let's make believe that it's all okay
there must be an explanation somewhere
or does consistency require me to say
well i had some criteria for what good
leadership looked like before i should
keep on applying those criteria and this
guy
unfortunately has like seemingly flipped
180 degrees um so it depends on what you
mean by consistency i i would say you
know
um
all right let's see
scroll down oops just skipped a bit
um
e demon says i know we have only certain
philosophical works from the past but
are there any other any names mentioned
in the books of works we wish we had
do you think it's possible that there
are great works in a cave i mean
anything's possible in the sense of like
sheer possibility as david hume has said
and if you can imagine it it's possible
right in a very
abstract sense um
you know the the best prospects for
getting new texts are those
manuscripts the scrolls from hercule and
am that they're slowly working their way
through
we might find some some new stuff
are there works that we wish we had i
actually did a video on that years and
years ago philosophical texts that we
know
existed
but
we don't have them you know
uh would it be would it be nice to have
them yeah um but what are we gonna do
all right uh
[Music]
says why did nietzsche end up crazy we
don't know
could be something organic you know
people put around the theory that it was
syphilis
we don't know
um
could have been um that there were some
you know lurking psychological
things going on that that he just hadn't
worked through and that broke him down
um i mean he came from a pretty goofy
family just look at his sister
um
we don't we don't i mean anybody who
tells you that they know for sure
exactly why nietzsche went nuts is is uh
either lying to you or full of crap or
trying to sell you something
um there's a lot of there's a lot of
places in in history where we have to
say oh
we got some guesses but that's as good
as it gets you know
uh diogenes any works of bataille that
you like in particular uh yeah the
erotic is is is pretty cool i haven't
looked at it for a long time but
um that i remember really enjoying that
armand the one or the many i don't know
are you
are we
just one
or are you something different for me
asking that question
ed keeley any new books on technology
that i would recommend i'm not like an
expert on on technology so no i don't
have any recommendations
luca how should i understand the
interplay between force and law and
hegel's phenomenology
chapter three it's not chapter three
it's the force in the understanding
section
is that is that the understanding is it
that the understanding fails because the
specific laws don't express the
necessity of force that is a thing that
happens you're talking about a big long
section in which there's a lot of
dynamic development um
i'm not able to give you like a nice
easy thumbnail summary of that
off the top of my head here i mean i
don't know how many videos i took to go
through that section of the the
phenomenology
um
all right uh
if i may ask what are your general
political views i'm virtue
so i think that um cultivating
uh good character is incredibly
important and that has implications so
that makes me
uh you know look at
our current republican party as almost
entirely corrupt and in many respects
evil the democrats are not you know
great
as an independent i'm going to throw my
weight behind them probably the rest of
my life because i don't see the i don't
see the republicans coming out of the
morass that they are are in
um so
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
where i think that
you know we should be able to come
together
as a community and the people who are
preventing that through their own greed
or their need to
be able to criticize somebody else you
know
uh to to whine about cancel culture or
critical race theory or other silly you
know stuff that doesn't actually uh
impinge upon you know real
life conditions except at little tiny
places
um
you know
they're the ones holding us back from
dealing with the great crises that as
rational animals we ought to be able to
deal with climate change we ought to be
doing stuff on that
we ought to have a much more
equal society you know these massive
inequalities of wealth big problem you
know
um american exceptionalism just stupid
at this point in time i mean there might
have been a time way way back where it
was somewhat justified but the stuff
that we're doing today just just silly
you know
um so you know
my politics wind up
basically aligning much more with the
left than the right i mean people who
call themselves conservatives today 99
of them are not conserving anything
they're just a bunch of hateful
uh you know people who want things to be
different than they they are worse than
they are just so it can be better for
them
and so they're not conservative because
they're not saving they're not standing
up for anything and and it's really
quite quite terrible um
one of my favorite biblical verses also
one of thomas aquinas's most favorite
biblical verses comes from isaiah woe to
those who call good evil and evil good
who call light darkness darkness light
who call sweet bitter and bitter sweet
so you know um
[Music]
who are the ones that are doing that you
got to ask yourself that and by the way
you know in the past i've been much more
a critic of the left than i was of of
the right when it was warranted you know
back in say the 1990s
um but now
you know who are the ones holding things
back who are the ones that are that are
you know justifying
much more evil
and
standing in the way of of fixing things
those are the questions you got to ask
yourself
um
i'm not even sure how to pronounce this
airdroke
i'm a student of geology what would you
have an advice see pitfalls for those
who not being philosophers by training
wish to study the metaphysics of our
disciplines no i strongly advise you to
study the metaphysics and the history
that's even more important the history
of your discipline so you can understand
how the concepts developed
that's a great thing to do
now you know
i wouldn't rely on wikipedia for that
or other
very schematic sources
but i would i would read around a lot
yeah it'd be really great
floyd mayweather asked who are some of
your favorite nouvelle t theologians
uh so the nouvelle theology or
resourcemont is as a particular
uh time in in uh um
church history you could say an
intellectual history or a philosopher's
well obviously maurice blondel right
um
and you know i mean i did my my
dissertation on the guy
um
[Music]
honorary lubeck very influenced by
blondel has a lot of cool stuff to say
and i enjoy reading his stuff
um i haven't been reading a lot of them
i mean eve simone i would say kind of
falls into that that category
and i think he's got a great book on
virtue by the way i'm kind of blanking
on the name of it
is it called the concept of virtue
um but it's really it's really quite
good so yeah
um
all right
cantat says are you familiar with
ferdinand ulrich if so what are your
thoughts on homo abyssus i've i've never
heard of either uh sounds like an
interesting title so
uh snowdrift moon can you say a nice
happy birthday to the boys tay and coop
over at machinic unconscious
happy hour so that's cooper i'm not sure
who tay is because i haven't been on it
for
for a long time but yeah happy birthday
uh is it the podcast is having a
birthday celebration uh or did both of
them somehow wind up with the same
actual birthdays persons that would be
very unusual
um fawad says can you talk about how the
will the power and self-affirmation of
one's drives relate to each other so if
we're you're talking about nietzsche
right so
nietzsche thinks that everything
involves or is will to power it's basic
to his metaphysics
self-affirmation
now self-reformation of one's drives
self-affirmation drives are not exactly
the same thing drives can be repressed
as a matter of fact exercising your will
to power you will in fact repress
something of yourself because you can't
you know let a thousand flowers or a
thousand drives bloom at every single
moment you'd you'd be just like a
walking contradiction and fall apart
right
so as a coherent being there is kind of
for nietzsche there is kind of like a
hierarchy of things you know governing
ruling each other and um you can kind of
pick between them and you can figure out
where you got your ideas about what
should be in charge of what came from
did it did it get you know like
pushed on to you by the society that
you're
a member of and there were incentives to
buy into it so you wouldn't get you know
beaten or ridiculed or stuff like that
you get to hold on to your job
are you are you you know finding
yourself not able to indulge your
your drives due to repression and then
feeling resentful about that i mean
those are all things that you would
you would um
take into account right
uh ed keeley any thoughts on dominical
lucerto's nature the aristocratic rebel
haven't read it
a lot of people asking me today about
books and authors i haven't read here's
another one david mondero do you think
peter calvage's book logic of desire is
a good introduction to hegel i don't
think i've read it i mean the title
sounds familiar maybe i read it if it
was around back in grad school but i
can't remember anything about it so
diogenes i've been accepted as an
external reviewer for an international
undergraduate journal will it be worth
my time it'll be worth your time if you
make it worth your time
i mean i don't know you or what sort of
things you've got going on
um or what you expect this to pay off in
as a reviewer of a journal
you don't do it because it's going to be
a great use of your time
as opposed to other things you do it as
like
service to the intellectual community
and if you
think that's a good use of your time
then i guess it will be you know it's
also kind of cool to see
how things work from the inside although
it's like the old proverbial
you know making the sausage if you're
squeamish you don't want to see how the
sausage is made editorial review
processes
are not always
as
fair and balanced and
uh well-run as as you would hope that
they are um but i it might be a good
might be a good um
experience for you you know i i i would
definitely do it
all right um
zeno says can an idea be original can
there be any more original ideas more
original ideas all the time i mean
that's one of the fortunate things about
our time is we have so much access to
stuff now it depends on what you mean by
original if you mean like nobody's ever
come up with any bit of this before
yeah i mean
that doesn't happen very often
there's nothing that precludes it from
happening in the future but
oftentimes you can be quite original by
reinterpreting things
[Music]
that you know
haven't been adequately
tapped out you might say right
daddy longlegs is the big lebowski
gospel of jesus no and as a matter of
fact i think it's really quite silly
that people
try to come up with something like
buddhism or anything like that
the movie's a movie it's a fun movie
uh it's basically about a guy who
doesn't have his [ __ ] together
and you know says you know
says man a lot and he's kind of a you
know fun character but it's not i mean
you you can turn anything into anything
but man given the vast variety of cool
stuff out there to like run your life
with
making the big lebowski into that seems
kind of silly to me
um sam any thoughts on the work of bung
chul han
never heard of him again so nothing for
nothing that i could uh say right
um
samuel how precarious is the job market
for teaching positions in the humanities
so the market isn't precarious it's
rather that people's livelihoods are
precarious right the market is the
market and it is what it is
and it's always been a crapshoot or a
lottery
um the only the only real leverage of
which would be um
arbitrary things like who you know and
where you went to school and stuff like
that it's not never been a fair market
uh it was cramped back when i got done
with graduate school
in the very early 2000s it's worse now
as a matter of fact there isn't a single
market there's a bunch of different
markets right and they could be
at the same institution so
for example
um you know a place like marquette down
the road where they
they they basically we know this now
they lied about uh the financial
difficulties that they were in and used
it to phase out a lot of positions
um and to try to push people into early
retirement and then not not fill their
positions
um kind of typical for
uh administrators
especially at at universities that claim
they have some sort of social mission
you know
they they don't um
their behavior shows that they're doing
something different they're they're
spending money on i think a 60 million
dollar new business school
uh they have they're sitting on a
massive massive endowment
and so
you know there's the market for like
full-time tenure-track jobs and
marquette will sooner or later be
advertising for some of them and then
they'll do the typical
song and dance stuff of putting out
advertisements and all these poor
bastards will have to apply to it and
jump through a bunch of hoops only
basically to get ghosted
and then you know four of them will get
brought to campus or three of them will
get brought to campus and they'll do
their song and dance and then the
committee will choose and then the dean
will decide whether or not they actually
get to hire the person or not
um and then there's adjunct work and and
i'll say too by the way marquette when i
taught there as an adjunct they were
paying adjuncts fairly decent the people
who were really getting screwed over
there were the grad students who were
were not getting like full tuition
reimbursement for the work that they
were putting in at the place and it's
different from place to place to place
but the job market is pretty bad
and it's not going to get better
any time soon in the united states
because schools have an mo they are
highly reliant on
non-tenure track
most often adjunct labor
for filling their classrooms and
students and parents
don't usually know what the actual
status is they're always you know
surprised like when i teach my business
ethics class and i say
it takes only one of you and the tuition
that you paid the portion of tuition you
paid for this class to actually pay
my salary where's all the rest of the
money going do you think you know
they're clueless about that
um
so the market is is is pretty bad is it
as bad in other fields i don't really
know i mean i think history is in a real
bind from what i can tell english maybe
bad i i don't know you know
all right uh
n and q
center what would you suggest reading
lacked of love and affection in
childhood and have problems with
socializing
oh uh i don't know
um i don't know if there's like
self-help books out there for that sort
of thing because i haven't
looked into that
i remember there being
books that i read quite a while back
having to do with adoption and
stuff like that but that's kind of a
separate issue but i can't remember the
names of them so
uh daddy longlegs would it be stupid to
say that jesus is the ultimate stoic it
wouldn't be stupid it'd just be silly um
why why try to bring two things together
that are clearly not the same thing
jesus can be interpreted in many
different ways from the the few
documents that we have
about this guy
um
stoic would not be
one of them um
i mean the one school that the quest for
the historical jesus often tries to
align him with is not the stoic school
but the cynics school right
wandering around engaging in diet tribes
that sort of thing um so it's just you
know kind of it's trying to bring things
together that don't really belong
together um
all right uh
gaussian eagle it's not easy to be stoic
we all have emotions well then you
definitely want to learn about what the
stoics have to say about emotions
because it's super super clear
with just a minimal reading and stoic
stuff
real stoic stuff not not the crappy fake
stuff that's out there on you know this
person who's trying to make a buck's
website or something like that but
actual stoic texts
that the stoics don't say you have to
repress your emotions or that having no
emotions is you know the point of
stoicism there are the good emotions the
you apothey right um
joy
uh rational fear or caution and rational
desire
so you know
you always want to inform yourself
better about that you also don't want to
use stoic in a lower case s
properly you know written it's capital s
just like aristotelian or platonist
right
another question about somebody i
haven't read rema what do you think of
luigi peyerson
don't know i've never read them so
[Music]
here's a question about metal
from ff do you like
genres like black death metal or dark
ambient
not into those at all um the
i i'm into what nowadays they call
traditional or we call it classic heavy
metal stuff from the 70s and 80s
some of the genres were developing back
then you know the very first beginnings
of of black and death the only black
metal band that i like is venom and and
a lot of their stuff you know isn't
isn't like that comparable to not what
we nowadays call black metal
um you know speed slash thrash slash
power these were all kind of loosely
defined terms at the time
was developing and i do like some some
thrash i like some power i like some of
course new wave of traditional heavy
metal and some doom i'm not into death
metal i'm not into black metal i'm not
into black and dark you know death metal
i'm not into
various other spin-offs i mean
prague metal a little bit but
you know not so much
um i think that kind of kind of got
tapped out for me with like prong for
example
um
back in the 90s so
uh you know when it comes
i'm into the stuff that goes way way
back and they're continuers more than
than uh the other stuff
all right um
puffy mcfart i'm new to philosophy was
wondering what a good chronological
order philosophical books are to help me
better understand what other
philosophers later on
i you know
again any any list that you can put
together is always going to be like kind
of triage there's plenty of them out
there um i i don't see why we should
take the limited time that we have here
to try to come up with a list like that
right off the top of my head
um telly have you read philip reef what
do you think of his work i have but i
don't remember enough about his work to
tell you anything because it's been a
long time
uh fraser says i'm i'm a solicitor an
attorney in scotland but i'm considering
a career change i'd like to be involved
with philosophy
as it is of great interest to me do you
have any advice in this regard yeah so
that's that's that's good
um
[Music]
there are lots of ways that philosophy
can be
applied in public and practical and
professional
life
i don't think that you have to like
totally leave your field behind to do
that as a matter of fact it's good to
hold on to a day job especially if
you're going to start building something
there's a lot of interaction between
philosophy and law historically right i
mean think about jeremy bentham what was
jeremy bentham's big thing it's not the
panopticon that was a side project it's
not just utilitarianism per se he was
about trying to change the british legal
system
which was very punitive and irrationally
so that's utilitarianism is is a way of
trying to make things better
and that's just one of so so many
examples out there
you're kind of fortunate
in that if you're interested in things
like stoicism or other philosophies of
life there are many people in great
britain who are doing that
i imagine of course that there's
probably more of that going on in
edinburgh then there is if you go
further north in scotland i don't know
about glasgow
and i don't know about the north that
much but there's a lot going on in in
the south
but you know
start looking for
communities that you can get involved in
um reading groups um
events things like that that you can you
can participate in
that's a really great way to do it
we're fortunate too now that like you
know we've got this vast international
network thanks to the internet i mean
look at this you know there's people
from all over the place participating in
this this ama
um obviously this is a very unstructured
activity and i don't know if anybody
actually learns an awful lot
quite frankly but there's there's lots
of other events
that you can you can participate in
um
what else advice
um
[Music]
you know reading is going to be
important
the one thing i will say is
people will
sometimes try to give you advice oh
don't read that person or you've got to
read things in this order you can read
any way you want to you know you don't
have to read things chronologically
you don't have to have read [ __ ] before
you start reading hegel doesn't help yes
but you know everything helps but you
don't have to feel restricted to where
oh i have to do this before i before i
do this because the person is telling
you that how do you know that they're
not full of crap you know
um there's
ask 10 philosophers what books you have
to read you get ten different answers so
um you know it's okay to rely on
yourself and you don't have to like
every philosopher that you're reading
you know we mentioned husserl earlier
i also mentioned bentham just a minute
ago both of them are boring to read both
of them are also valuable to read but if
you find that like it's not a great use
of your time to try to read you know
husserl's
um
you know ideas
you don't have to um you can there's so
many other books that you can go on to
and read instead
uh here's a really interesting question
from jay chung how do you think
kierkegaard would react to nietzsche's
work and vice versa
so
we know that george brown days actually
did recommend kierkegaard's work to
nietzsche um
we don't think that nietzsche as far as
i remember actually read it he did read
dostoyevsky of course you know going off
of gorg brand as the um
recommendation and so that's kind of
cool
brandeis is one of those few people who
started to see the connections between
them bran brandeis chest off you know a
few others
um were kind of getting it seeing this
this stuff
um i think kierkegaard would have said
that you know nietzsche probably has a
few good ideas to offer but that he's
you know fundamentally off base on
things and then he's an example of
where
um somebody who thinks that they're like
standing apart from society is really
being driven by this late you know
late modernity which is very pagan and
and uh you know
i think that's probably what kierkegaard
would have said but i don't know that's
that's that's a good question i'm sure
there's some speculation about about
that out there um
let's see john says thanks for the
helpful content over the years helped me
stand out
to in in my um
undergraduate philosophy classes and is
continuing to help me now in mat classes
good i'm glad you know that's that's
very nice um
you never know how much stuff is getting
traction or helping people out or stuff
like that so it's always it's always
great to to hear that
um thomas lodge are you a fan of
post-modern philosophy depends on which
post-modern philosophy you're talking
about i mean i
tend to use the word late modern rather
than post-modern because it means so
many different things to different
people including crazy crap that it was
never intended to mean by people uh who
you know read stephen hicks or jordan
peterson or pic pick the flavor of the
day of the right winger who's against
the postmodern you know
uh but yeah i mean i like a lot of
people that that get called postmodern
for different reasons you know
uh samida has got a great question here
[Music]
any tips for finding a purpose in going
to an analytic university when you're a
continental guy feeling sort of drained
from all the analytics stuff
yeah so if you're i mean if you're at a
place like that obviously find
stuff outside of your classes that you
can
use to connect up with other people who
are interested in what you're interested
in fortunately again we have the
internet we have like
all sorts of cool reading groups and and
you know things to participate in
um and you know there's there's stuff to
learn from the analytics it's not all
it's not all crazy you know
logic chopping garbage right um
i even think that you know we probably
if we want to be good philosophers we
should study what we could call a
classic analytic canon i mean you should
read
russell's philosophy of logical atomism
so you can be like wow that's what
people were into then and holy crap that
you know there's a lot of tech bros that
are into that now then they say the same
damn thing and here's why it doesn't
work and you should read wittgenstein
and you should read great great people
that people don't read like john wisdom
um who actually liked you know quite a
few continental figures iris murdoch is
another prime example of somebody like
that
um and you should you know you should
read ryle and you should read austin and
it's it's worth learning this stuff
um
and realize that that a lot of the
analytics don't have any idea just how
restrictive and deforming their points
of view
unfortunately are so you can be like oh
you poor bastards you know this is this
is the way that you think philosophy has
to be done but definitely branch out you
know and find
find other other things like that
all right so we're getting it's 123 now
um i'm gonna just start grabbing things
that i can easily answer rather trying
to do them in
in order um
[Music]
because
we're not going to be able to get to
everybody
um
all right
let's see here
um
here's an interesting one what should i
expect if i graduate with a philosophy
phd at age 37 same stuff as if you
graduated at 30
or 57
not a lot of jobs in the university
lots of prospects for doing work outside
of the university if you actually did
earn a phd you've shown that you've got
research skills and you should be good
at presenting things so there's a lot of
things that you can do with a phd you
just you're gonna have to have some
other you know
skills that that can tie in with that
right
uh brandon paul why does western
philosophy seem so disconnected to
buddhism i spent so much time searching
for answers and seem to have found them
in buddhism it seems crazy west and east
are connect aren't connected more well
buddhism itself there's no such thing as
buddhism there's
all sorts of schools of buddhism uh you
know
older theravada schools a host of
mahayana schools vajrayana schools
there's even newer schools now as well
right you know like
hans committed buddhism and stuff like
that so anybody who starts talking about
buddhism as a whole you can't possibly
read all the buddhist literature there
is in your entire lifetime anyway any
more than you can all the taoist
literature or confucian literature so
you know let's avoid kind of orientalism
and and type casting that way why isn't
there much contact between buddhism and
western philosophy um well because it
was happening over largely in india and
and china and then their you know
respective cultural spheres um there's
there's some connections i mean who do
who does talk about it schopenhauer does
right how well does he understand it uh
you know we know more about it now than
he had the opportunity to do
but there's you know there's plenty of
people who do talk about it so you just
got to go out there and look for it
neo anarchist will you ever do a video
on max sterner and why wasn't he
included in the existentialist or german
philosophy series i didn't do a german
philosophy series so i i don't have a
clue what you're talking about there
why wasn't he included in the
existentialist series because i didn't
get to everybody in the the series right
um why didn't i uh shoot stuff on una
muno who's more important than sterner
you know why didn't i ever get around to
all that stuff you know limited time
right it's not a anti-sterner thing
he's an interesting guy he's kind of a
limit point in philosophy will i do
videos on him um i've got thumbnails
actually for
videos that i intended to do a long time
ago but it's always a matter of finding
the time right we all get the same 24
hours every day i shoot videos mainly
based on what i'm
teaching in my classes if you want
sterner videos and you really really
want them
feel free to commission and pay for my
time to do them i've done that for
nietzsche videos and heidegger videos in
the past um anybody can you know
bump stuff up higher in the queue if
they want to but they gotta like you
know
they got to be willing to
to
make it worth not doing the other stuff
that i'm doing and doing the thing that
they're really interested in you know
um
all right let's see here
mon spider in fear and trembling on the
difference between knights of infinite
resignation and faith it seems the
former is susceptible to be becoming a
nihilist of sorts would this be
completely off base
uh yeah it would be completely
face when you when you actually read
why the
why the night of resignation infinite
resignation
is still
cool with things it's because they
recognize
some higher value that the thing that
they would really like
has to be sacrificed for it now a
neolist
there aren't any higher values right the
higher values as nietzsche says devalue
themselves
so
so long as you're a knight of infinite
resignation and that value still holds
value for you
you're not going to be a nihilist right
now
could is it possible that there could be
like some sort of
revelation to you oh man i bought into
this thing and it was all [ __ ] yeah
that happens to people all the time um
but
if the
single instantiation turned out to be
[ __ ] like think about you know a a
commitment to a political party on the
basis of this party is like furthering
humankind and you know writing injustice
and stuff like that those are those are
transcendent values
um and the party itself is an empirical
instantiation of that if the party turns
out to be a whole bunch of corrupt
[ __ ] that doesn't mean that those
values no longer hold but a lot of
people you notice
when their favorite instance of it
breaks down they're like oh this was all
[ __ ] too
you know
um
then you were never really a night of
infinite resignation that that might be
an actual test for it so that that's a
good thing to bring up i i'd say um
all right we got a
little bit of time left um
[Music]
all right so uh mike ron
your talks made me interested in
mcintyre's works tips for on dealing
with his works from a non-philosophy
background
um just you know read the works and when
you get bogged down um
read the people that he's talking about
i guess you know
or or look him up in some way or
something like that i mean mcintyre is a
rather
terse writer he's he's uh he's not a bad
stylist um but he
he can be a you know
rather
tough look at the examples that he uses
i would also
i wouldn't jump right into after virtue
maybe you read his history of ethics
first that might be helpful
and maybe some of his his works before
after virtue like against the
self-images of the age you know his
cultural criticism stuff
and then you know
kind of be prepared to work because he
is going to make you work for it
he's very he's very um
good to to uh to work on
um ben has another question here will
you ever do a series on bataille
maybe down the line if i if i'm teaching
but i but same sort of thing if you want
it bumped up you can commission my
videos
um i'm i'm receptive to that you know
here's a good one to go out on dennis
dixtra
i just started my master's degree in
applied ethics and i find it quite
intimidating to come up with my own
stances between all these philosophers
thoughts you don't have to come up with
your own stances
you don't have to be original right now
as a master's student you're supposed to
be learning
and you know taking stabs at things and
experimenting you know the
you get to play around with stuff you
get to come in and maybe say you know i
kind of think that virtue ethics is
where it is and then if you want to
reject that two years later and say i'm
a utilitarian now you get to do that
because it's your brain and it's your
education you know
um
nobody is going to
uh
you know there's there's nothing bad
that's going to happen if you change
your views or if you say you've heard me
say a lot in in this like people are
asking about this person and then i
don't know that person you know it's
okay
to say that it's okay
to
accept your
limitations it doesn't make you a bad
person
or not a real student or anything like
that
as a matter of fact if you're coming in
as a student you shouldn't know
everything
and you you shouldn't know everything
even when you leave you know
with a phd right a phd is just sort of a
license to get out there and continue
doing more research um it's a it's
really unfortunate that we we have a lot
of um
we have a lot of people and schools
that want too much of their students you
know the notion that like oh i gotta
publish something uh you know as a
masters student so i can apply for a phd
uh slot somewhere
that's [ __ ]
and i understand that there are some
places like that it's [ __ ] that they
put that sort of pressure on masters
students it's bad pedagogy it's bad
formation
and you gotta you know you look at the
people that are pushing that and you got
to say these are unwise people i don't i
don't want to go study with them because
clearly something is
going haywire and they're thinking about
stuff so you don't you don't have to
come up with your own stances it's okay
early on to be sort of like tracing out
somebody else's lines
you will eventually you know if you keep
at it you will start coming up with your
own stuff and saying well i i like this
about the utilitarians these are some
things i don't like now you're coming up
with something that's
more your own
so i think that's a that's a good one to
to go out on
i didn't get to everybody's stuff
i never do
so
um
sorry about those but glad we could talk
about the things that we got to and uh
i'm gonna go have something to eat
before i have to get on with my
next thing for the day
hope all of you have a great whatever it
is afternoon here
morning for some people evening night
time for others and i'll see you next
time